مشهد لم تنجحي ضغوط الغربيه براي موسكو في
تحيده
احترام المصالح والتعاون في عالم متعدد
الاقطاب تكون افريقيا احد مراكزه شكل
العنوان العريض للقمه الروسيه الافريقيه
الثانيه في سانت بطرسب
اود ان انوه بان القاره الافريقيه اصبحت
امام اعيننا مركزا جديدا للقوه وان دورها
السياسيه والاقتصادي ينمو بشكل كبير
وسيتعين على الجميع اخذ هذا الواقع
الموضوعي بالاعتبار
الى جانب التعاون الاقتصادي
ركزت القمه بشكل كبير على قضايا امن
القاره الافريقيه ونزاعات الداخليه
ومكافحه الارهاب وجاء انقلاب النيجر ليكون
مثالا تردد صداه بقوه في اروقه الاجتماعات
نقيم موقف شركائنا من خلال عدم التدخل في
شؤوننا الداخليه ونطلب منهم الوقوف الى
جانبنا في مواجهه التغييرات غير الدستوريه
يدين الاتحاد الافريقي التغييرات غير
الدستوريه التي حدثت في النيجر
احتياجات القاره الافريقيه من الغذاء
والحبوب احتلت مركز الصداره في قمه
بطرسبرج روسيا وعدت بتلبيه هذه الاحتياجات
وبشكل مجاني للدول الاكثر فقرا في القاره
بغض النظر عن توقف مبادره البحر الاسود
التي لم تراعي بحسب موسكو الشروط الروسيه
وحاجات الدول الافريقيه
الحديث يدور عن طرق امداد بديله للحبوب
الروسيه الى دول القاره الافريقيه خصوصا
الفقيره منها روسيا مستعده كما قال الرئيس
بوتين لتلبيه احتياجات افريقيا وتعويضها
عما لا يمكن ان يصلها من الحبوب
الاوكرانيه تريد موسكو القول انها عائده
بقوه وطويله الى افريقيا عوده تواجه
بمقاومه دول غربيه طالما اعتبرت افريقيا
مجالا حيويا لها لا غنى عنه
ووسط هذا الاستقطاب تقف افريقيا امام تحدي
بشان مدى قدرتها على ان تصبح قوه عالميه
وليست مجرد الساحه
التنافس بين الكبار زاور الجزيره سانت
بتروسب